c'est une tradition à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines la 18e édition
de la revancharde était programmé ce
dimanche 26 juin sur la colline
d'elancourt la course de vtt a réuni
cent cinquante sept coureurs venus de
l'île de france et de normandie
c'est un niveau qui est très très élevé
la fois sa route la fédération a
représenté aujourd'hui ils sont très
très forts moi je les ai vu passer ces
essais on voit qui s'entraîne on voit
qu'ils sont passionnés donc c'est
vraiment très très fort ils sont très
impressionnants
selon les spécialistes le tracé de 7,1
km réputé pour être l'un des plus
compliqués en ile de france on recense
près de 210 mètres de dénivelé avec une
cote de 300 m à 15 pour cent pour
terminer la course
le tracé est quand même assez relevé
avec des bonnes idées bonnes montées et
des bonnes parties roulantes donc
physiquement faut pas mettre au rendez
vous alors moi non j'ai pas terminée
j'ai abandonné parce que j'avais pas le
souffle et je vais pas non plus la
préparation physique nécessaire c'est
assez relevé un mois ça fait 18 ans que
j'organise j'avais fait circuit à vélo
ça va ça va couper les jambes avant mais
le circuit est assez dur il a été retenu
mon championnat de france vtt la semaine
prochaine le bce sky a brillé pendant la
compétition raflant deux trophées chez
les vétérans la course a été remportée
par le saint quentinois alexis durant le
cours a bouclé le tracé en une heure 23
florian richard a lui terminé premiers
du classement dans la catégorie cadet
une course également pour la bonne cause
les 4000 euros récoltés ce dimanche
seront reversés au profit des orphelins
des sapeurs pompiers de france